The average student loan borrower graduates
with around $37,000 in debt and a monthly
payment of almost $400. Considering that the
average starting salary for a college graduate
is around $50,000, that means that many recent
grads will have to fork over more than 10%
of their paycheck for years to manage their
college loans. That’s quite a burden to
be carrying at the start of one’s journey.
It’s no wonder, then, that many young people
faced with this prospect are looking for alternate
ways to prepare for their future, and one
such option is trade school, otherwise known
as vocational school, or CTE. The purpose
of these programs is to train you for a very
specific career, and they tend to be shorter
(and cheaper) than a four-year degree, so
you can get into the workforce quickly and
start making money.
If trade school is something you’re considering,
you might be wondering what kind of training
will offer the best bang for your buck. Of
course, salaries can fluctuate based on time,
region, and your level of experience, but
here’s a rough countdown of ten of the most
lucrative trades that you could train for
in two years or less:
10. Heavy Equipment Operator
9. HVAC Technician
8. Paralegal
7. Plumber
6. Electrician
5. Geological and Petroleum Technician
4. Sonographer
3. Dental Hygienist
2. Elevator Installer/Repairer
and
1. Radiation Therapist
Keep in mind, these are median salaries, meaning
half the workers in these fields make more,
and half make less. So while you probably
won’t make this much right out of trade
school, there is potential to earn an even
higher salary someday. Because of health and
safety demands, many of these careers require
licensure, or apprenticeships, or both. And
while some employers might prefer a bachelor’s
degree, all of these fields should be accessible
to someone with just a two-year associate's
degree.
Salary isn’t the only factor that makes
these careers attractive.The “job growth”
percentage represents how much employment
is expected to increase by 2026--in other
words, how much the demand for workers in
each field will rise--and you can see that
most of them are well above the general employment
growth rate of 7%. This might be because these
jobs are more difficult to outsource than,
say, computer programming or manufacturing.
Office buildings and homes will always need
plumbing and air conditioning, and you can’t
send a patient overseas for a sonogram or
a teeth cleaning.
This might sound promising, but there are
some important caveats. First of all, many
trade schools are for-profit, so they’re
incentivized to use aggressive recruiting
strategies, including exaggerating their results.
In 2015, one of the largest such companies,
Corinthian Colleges, was fined $30 million
and forced to close its 28 schools because
it was using fraudulent data to promise unrealistic
employment prospects to potential students.
And because these schools often target low-income
students whose loans are backed by the federal
government, there’s no incentive for them
to keep tuition low and no consequences for
poor results. This has contributed greatly
to the national student debt crisis, with
over 40% of for-profit college students eventually
defaulting on their loans.
Even if you find a reputable, affordable vocational
school, you should be aware of the trade-off.
That training may allow you to make more money
right after graduation, but in the long run,
a 4-year bachelor’s degree will eventually
earn a higher salary. This is partly because
the modern job market tends to reward flexibility.
It’s estimated that the average American
changes careers between 3 and 7 times in their
lifetime. Demographic and technological changes
can reduce demand for some jobs while increasing
others, and someone who’s trained in only
one very specialized skill will have more
trouble adapting than someone with a more
rounded education.
There are other benefits to a 4-year college
education that are harder to quantify, like
leadership, communication and analytical skills.
If after 20 years of fixing pipes, Pete decides
to start his own plumbing business, he’s
going to have to contend with economic theory,
social demographics, employee management,
client relationships, marketing and design…
He’ll be trading in his tool belt for a
whole new set of skills that a strictly mechanical
education might not have prepared him for.
There is a movement to make vocational training
more holistic, to include more extensive classes
on things like history, social sciences and
writing, so vocational students not only prepare
for a career, but understand how that career
fits into the overall economy, and how it
might change in the future. Unfortunately,
many people still see trade school as nothing
more than an alternative for people not “smart”
enough to attend 4-year college. Vocational
teachers in high schools often complain that
their classes are treated as a place to stick
“problem students.”
In fact, there are many reasons someone might
opt for CTE that have nothing to do with academic
capabilities. It might be simply unfeasible
to spend 4 years at an expensive university,
followed by lengthy internships before one
can even start to make an entry-level salary.
And a lot of people who seek vocational training
genuinely love their work. Many of the trades
on this list report higher than average job
satisfaction ratings.
Like any education, you should research vocational
schools before enrolling, and speak directly
to graduates about their experience. And ask
yourself honestly whether you’d be happy
practicing this one trade for the rest of
your life.
If the answer is no, you should think about
supplementing your training with more general
academics, perhaps at a local community college,
so you’ll have the flexibility to shift
gears in the future.
And that’s our two cents!
Hey guys! PBS Digital Studios wants to hear from you.
We do a survey every year that asks about what you're in to, your favorite PBS shows, and things you'd like to
see more of from PBS Digital Studios.
You even get to vote on potential new shows.
All of this helps us make more of the stuff YOU want to see.
The survey takes about 10 minutes and you might win a sweet t-shirt.
Link is in the description. Thanks!
We'd love to hear your personal stories about your experiences with trade schools or for-profit colleges.
Share them with us in the comments.